what will humans look like in 10,000
years
what about in 1 million years will we
look like this guy yeah probably not but
we'll definitely look different than we
do now what parts of our body would
evolve how long would evolving our
bodies take and who would win the
survival of the fittest this is what if
and here's what would happen if our
bodies kept evolving it took roughly 6
million years for humans to become what
we are today and modern humans have only
been around for about twelve thousand of
those years even in that short period of
time humans have evolved slightly we've
become about 10 centimeters taller and
now we can eat dairy foods after
childhood so if those things can happen
in 12,000 years where might we be
hundreds of thousands of years into the
future first we should probably figure
out exactly what evolution is evolution
is all about changes in the genetic
makeup that happened to a species over
time species with more advantageous
traits will tend to have more offspring
so those genetic traits will tend to
carry on to later generations
for example giraffes with longer necks
who can reach more food will be able to
survive better than giraffes with short
necks and they'll be able to have more
babies
who will likely have longer necks just
like their parents and as time goes on
the short necks giraffes will die out
and the long neck giraffes are the only
ones left that's why all our giraffes
today have long necks so how does this
apply to humans exactly well evolution
in this sense is actually very hard to
predict in the world we live in
don't need to worry about survival of
the fittest technology has effectively
cancelled a lot of that you no longer
need to worry about being the fastest or
the strongest this isn't 100,000 years
ago when you had to fight for your food
things like houses to live in and clean
running water make surviving it's so
much easier you never think to yourself
how am I going to survive today
but that's something our ancestors had
to worry about constantly it's not
guaranteed that 1 million years from now
humans will be stronger faster and
bigger than ever before after all having
children today is generally decided by
culture and personal choice rather than
the need for our species to survive our
future will be decided by the traits of
people who have children and how many
children they have if people who are
naturally overweight and have health
problems are the only ones having kids
over the next million years then that's
how the human race will end up but we
might not need to worry about any of
these natural occurrences instead we
could become completely fused with
technology before any of this happens
cybernetic arms brain chips and laser
eyes could all become possibilities not
only that but we also might be able to
alter a baby's genes before they're born
completely getting rid of evolutional
together this would allow us to get rid
of diseases and any other genetic traits
that might harm us but if we didn't have
this luxury and we had to evolve the
old-fashioned way there's a few things
that might happen we just need to look
at how modern humans have evolved in the
past twelve thousand years we know we've
been getting taller most likely due to
nutrition and that our brains have been
getting smaller but don't worry we
haven't been getting dumber our brains
are actually becoming more efficient so
in a million years we might be
incredibly tall humans with tiny heads
does that remind you of anything at the
end of the day human evolution is
incredibly difficult to predict
that's because evolution is primarily
based on our environment and who knows
what might happen to the earth in the
next million years we might need to
evolve to survive fires as the planet
will become so incredibly hot I so hope
I'm not around for that or in the next
million years we might live on other
planets like Mars humans would evolve to
look completely different there as
they'd be living in entirely different
conditions than here on earth
wondering what living on the red planet
would be like well that's a story for
another what-if